in other news at five o'clock metro  police are investigating a homicide in  north las vegas  officers say a store owner found a man  dead on a sidewalk near mlk and kerry  around seven  this morning when police and first  responders arrived they discovered the  man had a gunshot wound  police are urging anyone with any  information on this situation to come  forward  we do not know how long the mail has  been down on the sidewalk for  so we urge any witnesses please reach  out to crime stoppers there's reward  money available you can remain anonymous  the victim is described as a hispanic  man between 30 and 40 years old  police do not have any suspects or  witnesses as you heard there  at this time